après ma première victoire dans l'action
partielle adjoint fier de sa carrière de
députée triste de quitter la vie
politique
[Applaudissements]
conservatrice en 2020 notamment grâce au
Québec c'est une photo après les
réservateurs au Québec mais avec les
hauts de la politique viennent aussi les
bas
et Vinci de son poste de chef durant le
convoi par un caucus déchiré et
vindicatif je vais humblement quitter
mon poste de chef de la position
officielle qu'est-ce que vous en tirez
comme le son de cet épisode
c'était le le point de ma carrière pour
le tech parce que c'est c'était
difficile de voir
mon corps que son crise bonjour
maintenant simple député et avec un peu
de recul il porte un regard critique sur
la politique et sur le tournant plus à
droite emprunté par son parti
dans son dernier discours en chambre il
a servi une mise en garde sévère
trop de députés font la chasse aux clic
sur les réseaux sociaux dit-il et
s'enfonce dans la politique de la
division c'est
d'avoir un débat sur lieu et sensible
sur les enjeux parce que les parthésiens
sur Twitter
demandent une politique très fort dans
un certain domaine qui est responsable
de cette de ça tu le montres incluant
moi par ce que les réseaux sociaux à
changer la vie de politiques des
critiques dirigées envers tous les
partis mais on sent qu'ils vivent
surtout son propre chef Pierre
poillievre pierre est très intelligent
et très connu sur le réseau sociaux mais
pour la prochaine élection on doit
gagner plus de sièges dans les grandes
villes mais demande mais des politiques
claires sur l'environnement par exemple
et ça va être le secret de sorce pour
Pierre dans la prochaine élection et
c'est pas le cas présentement là non et
donc faut changer un peu pour gagner
dans les villes c'est ce que vous dites
absolument est-ce que le parti est
condamné à rester un parti rural
ça c'est le défi pour le futur je crois
également que mes pré
alaires ont été violés en fin de
carrière il dévoile avoir été ciblée par
l'ingérence étrangère
par la Chine avant et pendant les
élections générales de 2021 est-ce que
vous vous êtes senti personnellement ou
timidé et menacé personnellement nommé
mon mon mac quand même par l'été sur été
à été attaqué par l'état de chinoises un
nouvel emploi l'attend déjà dans le
secteur privé l'exil militaire est
ministre continuera de défendre les
anciens combattants et leurs soins en
santé mentale
eren Hull quitte son rôle de députés
mais la politique ne sera jamais bien
loin derrière ici Christian Noël
Radio-Canada
Ottawa